hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 13 hört zu und spricht nach
kann ich ihnen helfen kann ich ihnen
helfen ja gern ich suche eine hose ja
gern ich suche eine hose nein danke
ich schaue nur nein danke ich schaue nur
haben sie die hose in größe 52 haben sie
die hose in größe 52
ja wir haben die hose noch in größe 52
nein wir haben die hosen nicht mehr den
größe 52 nein wir haben die hosen nicht
mehr in größe 52
gibt es denn pullover in roth gibt es
den pullover in rot ja es gibt den
pullover in rot ja es gibt den pullover
in roth nein
oder gibt es nicht in rot nein den
pullover gibt es nicht in rot passen die
ihr die schuhe passen dir die schuhe
sie passen mir ja sie passen mir nein
sie passen mir nicht
nein sie passen mir nicht passt ihr die
hose passt dir die hose
[Musik]
sie passt mir nein sie passt mir nicht
nein sie passt mir nicht
kann ich
pullover umtauschen kann ich den
pullover umtauschen
haben sie eine quittung haben sie eine
quittung
sie können ihn umtauschen ja sie können
ihn umtauschen
nein sie können den pullover nicht
umtauschen
entschuldigen sie entschuldigen sie
wo ist hier die apotheke wo ist hier die
apotheke können
wo hier die apotheke ist können
sagen wo hier die apotheke ist wo
hier der licht wo ist hier der licht
können sie mir sagen wo hier der licht
ist können sie mir sagen wo hier der
licht ist
wo ist hier das wc wo ist hier das wc
können sie mir sagen wo ihr das vize ist
können sie mir sagen wo ihr das wc ist
wo ist hier die kasse wo ist hier die
kasse können sie mir sagen wo hier die
kasse ist
können sie mir sagen wo hier die kasse
ist
wo ist hier der ausgang wo ist hier der
ausgang
können sie mir sagen wo hier der ausgang
ist können sie mir sagen wo hier der
ausgang ist im ersten stock ist die
apotheke im ersten stock ist die
apotheke gehen sie in den ersten stock
gehen sie in den ersten stock
im erdgeschoss ist das kino im
erdgeschoss ist das kino gehen
ins erdgeschoss gehen
ins erdgeschoss im zweiten stock ist das
fitnesscenter im zweiten stock ist das
fitnesscenter gehen sie in den zweiten
stock gehen sie
den zweiten stock im dritten stock ist
der möbelladen im dritten stock ist der
möbelladen gehen sie in den dritten
stock gehen sie in den dritten stock wie
[Musik]
88 kochen kochen machen machen suchen
suchen einfach einfach die woche die
woche wie österreich
wie österreich die küche die küche das
mädchen das mädchen die bücher die
bücher sprechen sprechen gleich gleich
ich richtig richtig dokumente videos
[Musik]